this is grounded podcast with echo
Charles Jason gardener and me Jocko
what's happening what's happened echo is
trying to steer this before we hit
record he's trying to take which is cool
you a decentralized command you want to
talk about none good it's a good topic
but the whole top it could be broken out
much simpler than what you're saying
here's the topic here's what your
comments essentially what you're talking
about you see is it good look you see a
coach yelling at a kid okay let's just
take that this is from a tom to blast
jiu-jitsu
by the way post picture of a guy coach
screaming out a kid right that's it well
it's a no okay
clarify well the thing is here you could
you can simplify it but you wouldn't be
talking talking about the actual topic
or should I say concept that I'm talking
about okay what are you talking about
yeah so let's me and Jason we're
discussing okay tom two blasts yes James
jujitsu person has a post on Instagram
that says the picture is it's like a
meme picture a picture with words so
this is what the picture has on it four
pictures of what looks like college
football coach is yelling at a college
player four pictures of it ran out of
different ones above that in words it
says what champions consider coaching is
what the entitled consider abuse parents
if your son is gonna be great he will
take some ass chewings along the way
get ready that's what the picture says
okay no tom tom toms caption to the
picture says similar to what the what
the caption says in the online i'm stop
similar but different it's a little weak
in a pro training room before you ever
say you want to be one of the best in
the world at anything you don't simply
wake up with a gold medal a huge
business and tons of money you need to
be able to take the heat most break
before they even get started cool
right on so good okay no no baby but you
were all her from what you could
starting to say was that is it okay to
yell at a player yeah yeah I thought
that's what the topic was
yeah that's not know that whoa that is
one of the elements in this
comprehensive topic that I was talking
to Jason about and I kind of talked to
you about it seems saying yeah okay all
right well what's your take on it jock
good is no further traffic needed so you
didn't you you you don't have a take on
it no good take on it is hey the wait if
you're I can't wake up and just be the
best in the world or have a good
business ya know I don't see what the
issue is dude like seriously okay
actually no no there was yeah that
wasn't the issue that was an issue the
issue was in a hole right I mean you
know the reason I know this is because
some someone made a comment I forget the
name of whatever that said that
mentioned you and me in it so so yeah so
there and I forget what it said but then
so then that's what made me sort of like
analyze it in my own way so I think
everybody knows that if you're gonna
excel at something you're gonna even
need to get pushed yes and also if
you're going to be successful in life
you're gonna have to be able to face
some stress and some challenges so that
means you're gonna get coached hard at
some point now can you can you go too
far with it yes you can if you're an
abusive coach that yells at people all
the time that's gonna be a problem that
people hate the kids will hate the sport
they'll hate you and they'll quit which
is not good but if you're too soft on
them they'll won't be able to rise to
the level needed in a challenging
scenario so basically if you're yelling
all the time then you're wrong in and
you spent all your capital yeah yes
that's right yes because I can think of
times playing sports where I got a good
ass June and it's exactly what I need it
oh yeah yeah that tends to work like if
you're like a slacker okay limit until
you lose squads I story oh I wasn't a
slacker but I was sometimes a slacker
you know the kind where like you you're
good laughs you're not giving us any new
insight
okay enough to like be successful and
then you you know and then no I mean
slack after that I don't know but I know
someone that I work with back you that
is just like that but it's all good like
that but so anytime the coach would yell
at me like that like fly off the handle
for slacking it would work but if they
fly off the handle if like you're you're
you know you're doing something you make
a mistake you drop the ball or you you
don't remember a player or something
like that and they yell at you that
never worked it always worked against
them cool there you go settled
thanks Jason so we're up in your a oh
right now Jason when is it gonna get
cold cold there's already cold
we're in Spokane right now buddy yeah
long underwear on and that's what I'm
wearing everyday it's gonna get I think
Monday nights gonna be down a 20 degree
and you already did one winter up here
moved up here last December just digging
it yes just do so great is it like um
are you ready to just be completely off
the grid at this point oh well yeah yeah
I mean we basically live right on the
edge of the wilderness sorry are the
grid yeah we have electricity but we're
right on the edge of the wilderness you
know killed a mountain lion 80 yards
from my front door lunch dinner with my
300 Win Mag okay how far wasn't it was
well the shot was a 200 so here's what
happened uh-huh
there was a mountain lion I was hanging
around the house and we were out for
hike one afternoon and and saw this deer
that literally all the hide had been
ripped off his shoulder cuz it just
escaped and attacked by a mountain lion
so uh you know went and shot and put out
of its misery and then like a week later
we saw a whole bunch of Ravens and crows
outside and found where the cat had
killed another deer and elk cashy to
kill and so it had taken it and hid it
in some bushes and the crows had found
it so we put a game camera up on
on where to cached the kill and it was
in the woods like 80 yards from my front
door wait the cachet was yes or it's
actually called the cash by Lauren cash
did you know that I got corrected or
something his life got corrected on that
by someone a team three like it's not a
cachet it's a cache where you're like
okay cool exactly you know so it's not a
cachet it's a cache
even though it's spelled cachet yeah
alright so sorry so it's the cache is
eighty yards from the front door huh and
then we put the game camera on there we
see the Cougars comes back and and all
the photos are timely time-stamped so
it's they're feeding on the kill all
night and then it's looking around next
morning it leaves at the same time my
kids walk down to get the school bus so
so iris who's you know not really
usually cool with shooting predators
she's like yep that cat's got a go went
down to the sporting goods store I
bought a cougar tag because it was in
season okay and then went back up to the
cache a cuz they'll come back to the to
the cache like a week at a time feeding
on the kill and so then I went went to
it looked around found a good spot just
pick a spot with a clear shot 200 yards
away and then went and set up a shooting
position and popped out there the next
morning and drilled it right between the
shoulder blades
nice we ate it it was a big plastic ah
it was about 130 pounds gained two years
old because you see that story in the
news recently maybe six months ago with
a guy that they like this guy killed of
a cap and then when the cat was like 38
pounds or so yeah I was a desperate
basically a big kitten
yeah and it would it was an adult cat
and that still messed him I know that
thing did because you keep the thing
that's a we I think that a V V the
secret weapon of cats and dogs when it
comes to fighting them is they have like
they can they can move their spine way
more than we can like they can they're
so flexible or they can bend all they
can bend it so you think that you're
it's like this you could you could be in
their guard basically and they can turn
around and start running while they're
in their garden and vice versa so you
can like try and pin them down and
they'll turn like the back half of their
body around and attack you while they're
running so I think that's the real
problem is the amount of flexibility
that they have in their spine can do
that yes yes subduction wants for me to
hold my dog down yeah but even like my
son will try and pan my dog you know and
he has a hard time doing it yeah yeah
plus they've got you know a handful of
daggers yeah yeah yeah the cats for sure
the cats dude I mean if that thing's
coming after you even the 38 pound cat
no offense to the homes that fought that
thing off I'm just saying it wasn't a
hundred thirty pounds cuz 130 pounds he
probably wouldn't be able to fight off
yeah that thing would what about teeth
what's going on with the teeth they've
got big teeth are they gonna be okay
they can I get your throat out can they
get in here and saw Fergus with one like
so
iris watched one kill her dog that was a
wolf Chow and she said it just hooked
the dog flipped it over and Ben it
killed it like in three seconds flat bid
it right on the neck and he and snapped
it spine so I was hunting for elk and
I'm with John Dudley huge on lilius yeah
like one of the best hunters Bowen
there's no work but where I'm behind him
I'm probably like I don't know eight
yards ten yards behind him and we've
been we've been kind of stalking this
this group of elk and we're coming up
over this little Ridgeline and then so
then behind me is this other guy it's
our guide this dude named Mark and so so
Dudley's out front and then me and then
Mork and we've been we've been on the
trail for a while like on this group and
then all of a sudden like I see Doug be
he gets super super like amp like I
could see it as Isaac you know he's
giving me the most like get up here and
sure enough him in between us and the
elk that we were going after there was a
cat there was a mountain lion stalking
those elk
yeah and so Dudley like looks at more
our guide and he's like Derrick and so
Mort comes up easy sees like because
he's the exact quote from done he goes
can I smoke it yeah cuz he's thinking
you know and it was kind of it was kind
of weird too because we were we were on
these elk and we were like close in the
distance with him I would say and then
all of a sudden they like left and we
couldn't really figure out why and then
it became really obvious they smelled
that damn that mountain lion yeah and
but yeah you know what was cool so as
we're as we come he didn't know you were
there the mountain lion didn't know we
were there and he's stalking like we got
to watch him not for a long time but for
like a solid 30 seconds maybe him know
maybe maybe like two minutes I don't
know somewhere between 30 seconds in two
minutes I guess it was 30 seconds like
initially but then as we started it was
30 seconds that we watched him but then
we started following him and it was like
another minute of us following him and
Dudley wanted since he couldn't kill it
he wanted to get it out of there so we
needed to make some noise and like
Dudley but he does least trying not to
make enough noise to scare the elk but
another noise to scare this cat so he
goes he's like he liked stands up and
he's that kind of waving his arms a
little bit and then the cat finally
looks back and build because like he
make his own cat toys and it work then
the thing took off but yeah you could
see the way that thing moved
if that thing decided to kill you
because I was I don't know how big it
was I'm not I'm not good enough to judge
how big it was but it was big it was not
small it wasn't 38 pounds it was I would
say was at least it was at least 100 it
was at least as big as my dog at least
as big as my dog to deaths last year
from mountain lions there's one in
Oregon and one up here in Washington not
lions killing people yeah I mean a kid
like your kids that are young under the
ages of 10 that's going to be a real
problem
yeah because the your fear is is that
and and this is this is why we carry a
gun with us everywhere we go they just
cat runs up grabs your kid it's not
stopping it's just got us because
let's go so you know your only option is
to shoot it but see the thing is I think
you're making like a hostage shot right
this is a hostage scenario yeah well
what's your option
now I guess you don't have a very good
option yeah you're saying it's not like
hey I'm just gonna shoot it
no I gotta take a legitimate solid shot
on a moving target right that's partly
covered by my child's heart yeah that's
a nightmare now the thing is is that
that's why we have dogs you know and
it's like the targeting pit piece the
dogs are the find and fix piece and I'm
the finish so we go jogging in the woods
every morning and we both iris tonight
because it was that I was wearing a
sidearm but then we split up when we get
to run into different paces and she's
like we both got a carry gun so we both
run with 38 and then the dogs do the
dogs are awesome cuz they're gonna smell
it yeah it's crazy how good dogs can
smell let's go down a rabbit hole of
dogs but dang they can smell anything
and they can hear they know things like
when my wife gets home she my dog
he knows it's her you know what I mean
look well I'm I guarantee that he knows
exactly the noise that your car make oh
yeah and probably can hear it coming a
block away that's crazy so up here are
you still able to train at jujitsu yeah
we go up to Canada and train jujitsu up
there a place in rosalind or what's it
called Kootenai BJJ how how many like
students are showing up at us in the
adult class varies from 6 to 15 and and
what about the children's classes
they're about the no there's more
there's more kids up there than adults
and so it's like tenets well how are the
kids liking it
I love it we stopped going for the
summer mm-hmm
because when it's daylight out it's hard
to do it because we lose three hours
going up there because iris and I take
the kids of the kids class help coach
that one then there's a teen class than
the adults class and so but in the
wintertime we're all about it you still
do you do the three hour
yeah then we do secession it's a three
hour model and we just bring like you
know food for the kids and their iPads
or something so when we're doing the
adults class and the instructor up
they're super cool he'll let the kids
part if they're up for it they can do
the teen class as well because there are
some smaller kids in the teen class that
they can roll with but most times when
kids are spending after the the kids
class when you are training jiu-jitsu
now that you're training to just how
many times a week are you training it to
two times a week what do you like it
yeah oh yeah yeah at what point did you
realize like this is legit whoa when did
you start training like a year ago
something like that I started up a year
ago but the first time I did it and when
I had that moment like it was magic is
when um who's the Master Chief back in
Guam that was Steve Bailey yeah and so
that's the guy that got me into it right
and I wish I'd stuck with it but I
didn't but it was amazing because he
would just sit in the middle of the
class and there'd be 15 people there and
he would go a minute with everybody and
not break a sweat and somehow he just
don't top you the whole time
and I started training with him like I
think three weeks before another guy in
my platoon started and the guy that
started was really good at Taekwondo he
actually had like his own dojo or
whatever and um the first class he came
to we were sparring there and you had
three weeks on him which was enough to
mean yeah I got him in a rear naked
choke but then I felt bad I didn't want
to choke him out he's my friend so I let
him up and Steve's like oh no it's not
over and kept it going and now he's
embarrassed yeah so he just drills me
with a sidekick and then
pulled him down and I got him another
choke and then I just choked him out
that was yes that's the glory the glory
days of jiu-jitsu when no one knew
anything and that's pretty typical there
right there when someone gets caught and
they get like mad and embarrassed so
they think oh if I just go harder then
like well I can I can beat this guy
trying to wrestle me a robber and yeah
it doesn't work that was the deal with
all those gracie and action videos back
in the day like all he just thought he
could go harder and win okay people
would come in old greased up or have
some other scheme know what they thought
well you just can't believe it that's
the problem you just can't believe it
you cannot believe like when Steve
Bailey was like okay yeah you just lined
us up it was like me
Jeff Higgs and then like a couple of
their team guys and just like okay you
guys come and attack me and he just just
just crushed us I mean just you know
armlock rear naked choke it was only
like armlock rear naked choke I don't
think he actually knew the camera the
camera I think he only knew the arm lock
the rear naked choke any Americana right
that's what he knew it he's just worked
us over because no one knew he had teams
to I don't even remember learning the
guillotine I guess we must have learned
the guillotine yeah you had to have one
of the gear - yep you can't see the
moves if you don't recognize any like if
you don't know it yeah and it's like
just like I said for some reason would
just be on top of you the whole time
yeah that's like yeah he's a smaller guy
just push them up I'm bigger than you
push them off but then you sort of can't
and then you like oh I don't even know
why it really can't so let me just go
harder like you just don't understand
you just don't get it and you know
whatever your instinct is it's usually
wrong yeah yeah and so that's a messed
up thing right there and yeah cuz it's
like that episode of Seinfeld were
Costanza's doing the opposite of
everything he's gonna do let's go
Costanza the one kind of short fat guy
he just starts doing the opposite of
everything whatever is initial instinct
is and then his life just starts going
it go great yeah he goes I just do the
opposite of what I want to do and things
are going great for him and so when I
started doing jiu-jitsu again and I
would be get stuck in this mind riot
of okay right now I want to put my arm
here but that's exactly what he wants me
to do so I don't want to put my mind
there and I'm just overthinking it to
death and what about iris how she liking
it she loves it yeah is she putting
moves together T you guys can train
together yeah a lot of times because
especially when we're training in San
Diego everybody was giants there for
some reason especially in East County
and so you know was the most realistic
for the two of us to roll together mmm
and yeah you do you master your house
yet no not yet but yeah I'm gonna get
him yeah for like you don't need that
much either but actually with the kids
you need a little bit more yeah but we
got that school house on our property
which will be perfect for it that's sold
yet yeah what else echo can you invest
too much in the long term can you invest
I mean I'm sure you can but then lunch
you mean like in the long game along
your long game yeah in general I'm sure
I mean obviously we know from from just
our lives and from our basic fundamental
principles that you can go too far in
any direction even directions that are
considered to be good so yes you can you
can absolutely invest too much okay so
where is so where do you kind of draw
the line I guess you got it you gotta
think of us very like a specific
circumstance right - because that line
would be drawn like further okay so do
you know what it is I'm gonna save my
money for the future yeah things I'm not
buying food and I just starve to death
[Music]
as far as saving money goes yeah but
okay let's just go saving money like
like realistically I don't care I'm
gonna buy food so so when you save money
you don't necessarily not spend your
money so that BS going too far well
actually actually no what you just said
is wrong when you save your MA
no I'm saying pragmatically in the real
world
I'm not saying let's leave the concept
all right no I get it but no I know when
you when we're saving money if you're
saving money for something you save
money for I don't know jacket
there's only here right you're still
buying food cuz you gotta live to wear
the jacket you got it that's very
pragmatically you're not gonna starve
yourself okay in the name of saving
money okay both of them okay okay so
actually I'm not even really necessarily
if you take it too far it won't
necessarily be in that direction it'll
be oh I'm saving money not for something
specific but I just want to be like
frugal for the long game right okay so
if you be too frugal how can that kind
of bite you not talking about starving
yourself short of starving yourself yeah
so you go to buy a tool right yeah you
go to harbor Freight you can get four
very inexpensive a tool that works but
the thing is gonna break in six months
or you can go buy a more expensive tool
that's gonna cost more money up front
over the long haul it's gonna be cheaper
because you're only buying one instead
of like the three or four harbor freight
tools you would need and so then then
you're looking at either playing the
longing or the short game based on how
much you invest up front right so the
it's same thing with cars right kind of
thing like you know you can buy a cheap
car but not reliable you spend all this
money on yeah so this stuff because of
the car or you buy a more expensive
reliable newer whatever yeah it's got a
it's got a warranty on it yeah kind of
the same deal no right so where's the
where's the line in saving money though
the the line is you have to just do the
risk versus reward the the cost versus
are alive I mean what's what Jason just
said you can be like okay hey there's
some tools that if you're only gonna use
it one time you know every once why you
got to go to Home Depot and buy some
tool that's gonna use your loo you know
you're gonna use it
one time you go to Harbor Freight yeah
then you go to Harbor Freight get
something that's gonna get you through
that particular job but if it's
something that you're gonna do
repeatedly or you're gonna need or that
has broad applications across a large
spectrum of scenarios then perhaps
invest like I have a really nice I have
a really nice saw yeah yes like a really
nice song like what like a table saw or
just a regular yeah like a nice table
saw I've actually have pretty nice tools
you know cuz tools like that but there's
a couple tools that I've achieved you
know the tool that you use to replace
the screen and your screen door like if
I worked as a store installer I would
have gotten the $32 version of that it's
like a wheel with the metal and a
bearing or something like that no I have
the plastic one yeah it's the only doors
that I'm fixing with a screen on them
are mine it costs $4.00 so there's an
example there's there's I mean you can
use Excel to do a lot of this stuff and
that's something that this winter when
the days get shorter I'm gonna learn how
to use Excel I know a guy that that used
he looked at it in Excel and he saw that
it made more sense for him to lease a
vehicle because he wasn't driving very
far than it was to flat-out buy it
anyways so good
seldom that's the situation okay yeah
like if you don't drive I've heard that
before scenarios that dude there are
scenario yeah there are scenarios that
that does happen even like renting and
stuff so okay good what about
health-wise like and health is a broad
one let's say diet will say just just
eating right your diet you can clean up
your diet can you focus too hard on the
long-term with diet and what does that
look like I'm sure there's many ways in
fact I can probably thought okay well
let's do it why are we trying to eat
healthy yeah just stay healthy right so
let's say you know what what people
aren't calculating into their health is
their mental health that actually plays
a big role in your overall health so if
you are eating rice cakes
and what else do people like that eat
the rice cake celery if you're eating
rice cakes and celery mm-hmm and oh
that's cool you're skinny but you're
depressed that's gonna be a problem
yeah so yes you can go too far sometimes
you gotta have a mint chocolate chip
milkshake yeah or whatever or what if
your particular scenario has you sort of
the head of household situation and your
dietary guidelines or should I say rules
I guess in this case are affecting your
relationships in the household that's
befallen I almost crossed that line once
yeah I know so my wife was like you know
I was I was going a little bit too
hardcore this is back when I was still
in the Dave's and I was going a little
too hardcore with you know like keeping
it clean and everything and so I got
home and I was she had made like
whatever chicken or whatever and corn
mm-hmm and I was like I was like I was
like seriously like I've been asking you
not to like feed our children actual
poison and your feeding of corn and
she's like she goes it's a vegetable and
I go it's a great yeah there she was
actually talking about she's an idiot so
you almost you didn't quite cross the
line cause he didn't down reel it back
in yeah that's what I do yes
or like when you're a little kid you
saving you say I want to save my money
so you're saving your money but not as
much money as maybe your dad wanted you
to
so your dad gives you [ __ ] about it
every single time like any time you
spend a little bit of money say I'm
saying then you don't really like your
dad anymore that much yeah so like
everything else we know for a fact that
if we take anything too far even good
stuff it'll be a problem yes you've been
playing the long game which I kind of
gathered was kind of the game yeah well
you can even don't care now wait wait a
minute journey before destination
okay apply that yeah no you you you have
to be present in the moment right so if
you're always focused on where you're
trying to get and not the path to get
there then anything that was more
important a balance again elements I
could dig it dig it I was surfing with
stoner uh-huh we're literally surfing
it's a beautiful day and we're out it's
me and him at my break by my house yeah
it's it's like just a beautiful Southern
California day the waters warm the Sun
is out we skipped work whatever it's all
good and we're out there and he's like
bro like like how am I gonna find a
happiness like how am I gonna get got am
I gonna get happiness and I was like bro
I'm like this is it yeah like this is it
man like this is actual this is it like
this is it you don't have to go anywhere
this is it and and it's the exact same
thing that you're just talking about
Jason like if if he's sitting out there
and instead of thinking like it actually
life doesn't get any better than it is
at this moment in time we are surfing
the waves good there's no crowd it's
just it's just awesome like hey and and
you know he's over there thinking about
work or about whatever something else
about how can I land this position or
how can I make more money or whatever
whatever crazy thoughts he was having he
was having them instead of just being
out there going you don't want this is
awesome and oh I'm gonna catch another
good wave so yes yeah gotta pay
attention to the what do you say the
journey not just their destination
journey before destiny I mean before
destination at time now it's uh from a
fantasy novel I was reading called Waya
Kings and there was a thing in there
that said journey before destination on
strength before a couple other really
squared noise
let me look it up geez that's great pull
it up right now
I wouldn't we said we kind of agreed
that it was balanced this is with like
35 seconds of thinking about it where I
think that yeah the journey might be
more important because look all these
little goals right I mean there's
exceptions for sure but every time you
reach like some goal that you have
short-term whatever even long-term
you're kind of like cool and then you
reflect on all remember all that you
know you kind of the the the goal
doesn't really it seems like anyway that
the goal doesn't come with you for the
rest of your life like but everything
you learned along the way sort of does
you know we can apply it to other little
goals or whatever and also when you
reach the destination that like the
luster of that sort of fades yeah yeah
you know I I'm only happy at the
destination for about point the full
thing is life before death strength
before weakness journey before
destination yeah that's cool well the
first two pretty obvious yeah piñon but
the and think about think about when you
have a bunch of goals right and you're
like all the goals are more important
let's just say and you go first goal yes
I did it okay next goal look I did it
like these goals are important but after
you stacked up 20 of those dang those
goals were sort of part of that journey
assume saying so they become the journey
you know it's like being a parent to
like waiting for your kids to get older
yeah but then every aspect is so awesome
and it's like whoa I need to really
enjoy this day when they need me to read
a book or every little aspect of
parenting them I need to slow down and
be present in the moment and going this
is so cool yeah because the the the
parenting thing the kids that they don't
gradually mature it's like one day
you're hanging out with your kids and
everything's cool and you're their dad
and then like the next day they're on
their own program
and and that's what you want right
that's what you want you want them to be
on their own program but yeah it's not
like if you don't get any warning sign
this is one day you go oh one day you're
like hey do you want to go you know want
to go you know walk down to the
tidepools what's wrong you like to
yesterday yeah and then they're like
well no because I've got a friend coming
over and you say oh okay I'll be over
here by myself that's such a good and
you know people say that a lot right
whether it's like hey cherish those
moments and they say that a lot but they
do it's like man it's weird how we don't
get it sometimes because you can and
here's a little test you can do so let's
say you have a in my case six year old
and three year old I can look at videos
or something like two years ago
it'll be like oh where did that time go
and I was like two years so what's gonna
be when they're like 20 never I know
yeah like you can do that like two
months ago even like I'll remember that
oh I wish I would have just did more on
that day you know kind of thing and man
if yeah if you can keep that in your
mind it's helpful just reinforcing that
being the being the present being in the
now yeah aiming at the future just
balanced again yeah I think Sarah
Armstrong put it really well
the days are long but the years are
short oh yeah this is a good wave so
yeah you know cuz you get caught up and
like I wish this kid would just go to
bed mmm you know and like no actually
yeah yeah and for me my experience has
been that my kids it was like all of a
sudden they were adults yeah at least
they're all of a sudden they were yeah
yeah adults you know which is cool
that's what I want you didn't want to be
and then I guess may have been your kid
cuz you spend a lot of time away though
I'm gonna work and stuff like that so so
you might have a maybe slightly
different experience from someone who
isn't this is it were you you weren't
away right what do you mean like all but
how old are you kid
eight and seven okay so I guess yeah did
you retire you just [ __ ] maiya
so they they've been
through two deployments okay yeah yeah
but if you're a parent who's there all
the time I'm just saying that
gradualness they might have a little bit
it makes me much more gradual yeah yeah
that's not what I'm talking about though
hmm
I'm not talking about half oh when it
hits you I'm not talking about how when
you when you you know I haven't seen you
in a year and then put on 40 pounds to
your belly and I'm like dang what
happened where as opposed if I see you
everyday I might not notice it that's
not what I'm talking about I'm talking
about your kids will in a very short
period of time go from being whatever it
is I guess dependent on you to being
independent and that will happen very
rapidly and it wasn't like you know I
went away for six months and came home
and Wow
no it was like it was like Oh yesterday
you wanted to go to the tide pools with
me and today you want to go to whatever
Jessica's house for a kickback did that
really happen to you the world the word
kickback certainly came into play well
what about the title was it actually the
like did you really in real life get
rejected from the title probably I don't
I don't remember it pretty romantic
sounding but well that sounds like fun
something fun to do with your your kids
yeah the tide pools are awesome yeah the
tide pools are awesome there's creatures
in there you know Holzer like you can
see awesome plus do I know why this
isn't good time yeah
but yes I do I know exactly what you
mean ah now that you mention it because
like it's almost like your mind is
paying attention to these elements one
day and then here's one one day in one
day in one day that's the transition
period your daughter your daughter your
daughter is not gonna want to hold your
hands when you're walking down the
street she will do it on Tuesday on
Wednesday she won't that's gonna happen
that's my fear that does happen yeah I
believe that's what I'm saying there's
no that's not a that's not I mean that's
a transition that takes place boom
you're going to go from dependent to
independent yeah or yeah and it that
seems like that could be actually two
things that could be two ways of that
happening one is stuff that's building
in them and then just one day they're
like wait I don't wanna hold your hand
anymore right so it's like boom just
like that or it's another thing that
that that maybe one day they figure
something out that is just you know that
one thing you figure out that applies to
so many other things so now I'm a
different person kind of thing no sounds
totally different you know it can happen
like that then when it hits you as dad
just sort of being dad you're like dang
you're like a different person your
ability to influence them is huge when
they're younger and then you got to
figure out the trajectory you want to
get them on because everyday it's
limited and limited so you know when if
you're trying to correct problems when
they're 17 that you should have fixed
when they were 7 you're messed up well
I'll tell you one thing that I've
noticed about my kids is a ton of the
influence that I had on my kids
it was seeds that were planted that came
to fruition later like I'm like I will
say wow that you know one of my kids
will do something or say something and
I'll know exactly where it came from
mm-hmm but I haven't seen it I hadn't
seen it before from yeah you know what I
mean uh-huh
it's like you see someone do a move in
jiu-jitsu that you you don't you didn't
expect them to do and you go but you
know that they learned it from
you know it's like one of those things
so I noticed that with my kids now that
they're older you know I'll see my one
of them will do something they'll say oh
I know exactly where they got that from
and I know it's actually from me but
even if you were to ask them it's like
there's a good leadership right yeah
they don't even know where they got the
idea from they just know that that's the
right thing to do or the way that it's
good or whatever so and I think if you
try and cram those things down their
throat that's gonna be a problem the
only way you can get him in there is we
have just being around my oldest boy is
is like I think he's about on his fourth
week of army boot camp and he had the
opportunity to call me last Sunday and
he sounded so good and so it's crazy
there's a Facebook page and I can follow
what has come fate like every day they
post what they're doing in boot camp
hey and they're doing like way better
stuff than we did a neighbor's camp of
course they're out in the rifle range
yesterday they got gassed two weeks ago
I was like hey buddy
you like that gas it was horrible you
know medical skills doing their radio is
doing lots of good stuff that's awesome
and you know before he was going I'm
like Haiti desert there's like they have
a pretty badass credo too was like I am
I stand ready to deploy and engage with
my nation's enemies and all this good
stuff yeah when I was a Haiti boot camp
they well first of all yeah navy blue
campus it's just if you're going in to
be a seal Navy book boot camp is not
what you're looking for but I wanted
that too I wrote you know you could
write some kind of you got to write
notes or whatever and I wrote like I'm
one of those like this brainwashing
seems to be working well like then the
guy all freaked out on me that my my
boot camp chief not not on me cuz he did
it was an anonymous like you had to fill
out like what are your thoughts on boot
camp or something like that and I was
like being a cynical little [ __ ] kid
you know I'm like the brainwashing seems
to be working well
yeah but if you come out of boot camp
and like you're standing around on them
automatically you're at parade rest or
whatever exactly the brainwashing seems
to be working well I was like are you
folding your clothes I'm folding my
clothes yeah good so pay attention of
those kids yeah well how you can tell
like that that is true is not only can
you see your kids kind of doing stuff
like oh I used to do that or maybe I
don't even remember teaching them that
but they do it just the way I do good
and bad by the way mm-hmm
or or and you can like give stuff that
you do that your dad did I'm not sure
yeah that's do you yeah you got some BC
yeah a say stuff like you know how you
say stuffing or when you're a kid and
you're like ah I wouldn't say that
that's a dorky or whatever that's such a
dad thing to say and then when I kind of
grow up you say yeah I I know I do
things that are considered to be dad
things yeah but you can't trace it back
like you know my daughters were wearing
shorts that were too short in my opinion
for school and so I was walking around
our house with a pair of shorts on with
them hiked up my ass yeah I'd say it
worked all right
yeah I'd say work pretty good but you
probably had like a tan line you know
like the tan line that's I can tell this
the shorts are too short when there's a
tan line hmm
I don't even know and that's the
guidelines sure then again or if your
daughter's used to wearing short shorts
and they're too short you don't know it
because I can't see the tan line
there is no tan line so I guess that's a
flawed you know very measurement logical
yeah well cool hey man I'm on
tonight cooee you'll get to the food yes
sir all right this is the grounded
podcast we have another podcast called
jockle podcast if you want to listen to
that we got the warrior kid podcast if
you want to help us out you can go to
the chocolate or calm or you go to
origin main calm and shop for stuff
thanks for listening we'll catch you
later and stay grounded